what's up everybody hello beautiful
people welcome to the show today i'm
excited to be talking to you my my
lighting is a little overexposed
mark says i look a little angelic it's
just revealing my true nature but let's
get into it
today we're going to be talking about
the redesign of the capital one logo you
know what time it is
we're going to be talking about logos
that you love to hate
this is logo redesign and today joining
us is
indica tilika i hope i said that right
and
he's from colombo sri lanka and here are
some of his work you can see it here
really nice clean solid work and i love
that you're from sri lanka because
i think you may be the first person
that's been on our show from there so
i'm very excited okay this is
i would agree maybe a universally hated
logo there's all kinds of weirdness
going on here
in here so i'm looking forward to what
you're gonna do with this
but the first question i have to ask you
is why
why did you pick the capital one logo to
redesign
hey um first of all i gotta thank you
and the team for
uh inviting me to the show um
so before i answer that question i i
wanted to
take you through the process of
selecting this logo
yeah it's it was tougher than i thought
uh because the bigger the brand is the
chances of
you having a bad or okay logo is pretty
slim
so i had some
some other options but i was leaning
towards capital one
and i also remember that uh in one of
the
episodes uh sagihavi mentioned that it
was his dream plan so
i knew i was on the right oh
okay very interesting good reason yeah
okay moving on i'll just take you
through the
uh how the the company came to be in
1994
a company called signet financial
corporation
they separated the credit card division
and
named it capital one and in 98
they expanded to auto loans and
in 2005 they went to retail banking
so a small credit card company
became a fully fledged bank but the
problem was
that the logo didn't really evolve with
the brand
so it the word mark
stayed the same and in 2008 they
introduced this swoosh people call it
the boomerang swoosh
and yeah the design community didn't
really
like the fact that they introduced a
swoosh in 2008 which was
quite dated and uh but they
somehow stuck to it and it even featured
on
bad logo list by design blocks but
[Laughter]
in 2016 they went for redesign they
made the whole logo flat and
made the colors a bit darker
it's a step in the right direction but
it wasn't enough in my opinion
so for the reasons why i'm
redesigning this uh there's a bunch of
reasons the
the swoosh and obvious reason and
uh the fact that you have this serif
and sensitive combination it
it felt a bit weird for me
it sort of creates a split personality
so to speak
for the brand it's neither a serious
brand or a casual brand so it's
somewhere in between
and they have this
baseline shift going on uh where the one
portion of it
it sits below the baseline of the
sensative portion
uh it feels a bit awkward and and the
whole
logo lock up with the swoosh it creates
a odd shape
and when you're placing it somewhere it
becomes tricky
yeah can you do me a favor can you just
move your mouse pointer off the screen
so it's not there the whole time
uh it's not i think oh i see it is
mark do you see the mouse pointer right
under the capitol yeah
we see it but for some reason he says
that he was moving it and it's not
changing
i don't know what's going on i don't
think it's like
jonah it's jonah i know it's jonah's
fault none watch
there you go you see two mouse in it no
i i see just one frozen pointer
there's one there do you see it there
somebody's uh
no i don't see yours jonah i do not see
yours so forget it we'll just keep going
on we'll just live with a mouse pointer
always pointing to that
all right all right okay okay moving on
so um here are some examples of uh
their logo usage and you can see the
issues uh in
some of these the logo on the uh the
mobile app there in a small scale you
can't really
see the details of the logo and for the
app icon it's a weird
crop and you can't really identify the
swoosh
there are problems with fitting the logo
in
small vertical spaces like the signage
the swooshes jutting out so problems
like that
and uh there's another teeny tiny
problem that i found
um this
oh my gosh is that a competitor that was
my reaction uh
initially initially actually i i thought
that this was
part of capital one itself maybe it was
a division because i was not familiar
with the brand when i started digging
into this
and only to find out that it's actually
a
completely different uh bank
altogether it's a small bank based out
of las vegas
and uh they obviously copied it from
capital one right
yeah uh
the lawsuit should be in order here come
on
it it was the other way around
surprisingly
so in in 2006 a company called uh
first national bank of marine they came
across some
image issues and they had to rebrand and
they came up with this logo
and for some reason in 2008
to two years later capital one
introduces the boomerang which makes it
very similar to credit one
but uh capital one being uh
the giant that it is about 60 times
biggest
credit one they didn't really have a
problem with it because of their
marketing budgets people
thought that credit one copied the logo
not the other way around
so it's a it's a small issue but it's a
issue nonetheless
so here i am looking at the competition
uh the other top players in the u.s
market
and some global ones
and and the characteristics that you
see is that they are all moving towards
uh
sans serif and clean uh minimal designs
they have very strong marks and they're
all
combination marks most of them and you
can really separate the symbol
from the word mark and it
the the fact that you can do that it
makes the logo
more versatile
these are the marks the symbols
separated
and the common thread between these
uh is that they're bold and strong and
they sort of
convey some stability as a financial
institution should and they're very
simple
uh most of them are simple enough
to be drawn on a piece of paper from
memory that's the
right the the best test for a simple and
memorable logo
as uh sagi mentions and
some of these are actually pretty old
designs
like jspank logo that was done in 1961
and the deutsche bank in 74
and hsbc in 83 and also
citibank in 1998 um they're still using
them
they're still as clean and modern uh
as the others so i set myself
a
brief for myself to come up with a
strong and
simple memorable mark that was my brief
and in my research
i digged up an old style guide the
not the most current one but uh i guess
the
brand attributes doesn't really change
over the years too much
so these are the keywords that they
describe the brand with
they're bold innovative authentic very
friendly
trustworthy so i
wanted to instead of coming up with a
mark
out of the blue i wanted to base it
off of something from the brand
ecosystem
so i was digging into the sub brands and
any
any other products that they had and i
found this uh
it's called capillary one labs which is
the r d department of uh the bank um
they're they are sort of spearheading
the bank's innovation and it sort of
embodies all
these brand attributes of the bank and
they are the ones responsible for
introducing the
capital one cafe concept
and you know their virtual assistant
so that was my starting point that was
my springboard
um i was taking this c1 element and
i was exploring how i can uh
sort of reverse engineer the master
brand so to speak
right it looks like the periodic
table of elements it does yes it does it
derives from that whole lobster
theme right kind of science vibe
so next i have my process video
should i play it right now yeah yeah
let's play it
i we still believe indica that it's your
mouse
pointer that's still stuck on that
screen can you move your mouse again
no maybe you scream uh it's really weird
we can't figure out it's someone's
potentially saying it's like it's quite
odd though
you see it everybody sees it we're
moving every computer we have and nobody
can get rid of the mouse
is it still is it it's still there it's
still pointing at the letter h
and i'm hoping that see no nobody can
seem to get that to move jonah all your
computers
right because it's going to just be
burned into this it's all mine
okay all right cool all right let's go
go ahead and play the video for us
in a second let's read some comments
chris because he has to
he has to switch over yeah let's let's
go into the comments mark are there any
comments here we need to talk about
yeah so brian butler he's just saying
that he's actually put a lot of time
into looking at this logo and
redesigning it since the have interview
that you had initially so i think a lot
of people are thinking the same thing
this
logo just needs a refresh yes so you
guys can
those of you that were inspired by the
episode
let's uh play along and see if you make
the same or similar decisions as indica
does
i think it's interesting a lot of these
financial services companies are trying
to
almost look like these tech companies so
you can see a lot of their logos
moving that direction but a few of them
including capital one haven't really
done that yet so i think it's written
ready
all right there we go okay
all right so talk us through what you're
doing here
so i'm jotting down some notes from
the old logo
questioning the slant why is it tilted
but i'm liking the colors because we're
changing everything i'm
deciding to keep the colors and writing
down the name
seeing how it looks as a shape
and drawing this you're doing this in
photoshop
yes with a wacom mm-hmm
is this typically how you work uh
usually i
work with uh just paper and a pencil but
uh because i'm doing this i wanted to
record everything
i see that makes sense so
the reason why i'm doing this instead of
just using
uh regular fonts is that when you do
that you tend to
fall in love with something and you sort
of settle for
the font and you don't really explore
so i found that doing this it
it gets your idea on paper on on the
screen in
this instance but and then you can find
a font that
goes that's similar to it
or at least you can draw it yeah i also
saw that you were thinking of systems
too because you're
trying out capital one with other words
attached to it for the sub brands right
i was trying it out yes yeah the capital
one bank capital one credit
capital one loans it's very important to
think about how the system is going to
be used especially when you're doing
really large scale identity
yeah now i'm deconstructing the current
logo and
seeing whether i can fix it identify
some issues by doing that
find a stacked version of it
now i'm working on a symbol a mark
i'm exploring a capital one like a
upper case one it's sort of starting to
look like a building
a structure so conveying stability again
more exploration
now i'm combining the c with the one
this was starting to look like a
low case a and i'm
trying this circular
looking thing yeah
hmm i found that the the the one was
getting lost so i'm
trying to bring that out a bit it's very
interesting
for me to see other designers work in
progress because sometimes
in your sketch i see something else
because i happen to know
what he winds up with so it's kind of
like oh there's something there that
if we were working together i was like
oh why don't you try this thing because
i see something in there
all right so
at this point i'm just uh doing as many
options as possible
so i'm not really thinking about what
i'm gonna finalize
the design with
how long is this taking you in real time
um so the whole process from uh
the research to the final coming up with
the final logo was about
25 hours that's within a span of
about one and a half months it was
working slower but uh
and for the price that helps to give
everybody some context
oh different shape here
uh yeah i'm i'm trying to create an
abstract shape for the c and the y it
sort of
represents some growth yes
that's something that i'm going for like
it's progress it's growing
that's what i'm looking to bring up a
comment here that
uh picaran bora had brought up so
just in reference to the direction a lot
of logos are going to these days
i think he was just mentioning because
of the digital area era
a lot of companies are trying to fit
that logo into an app icon
so that it's all uniform in that system
yeah it makes sense you have to think
about where the logo is going to live
most prominently
and especially if they're going to have
an app having the current capital one
logo
is not going to work well at that size
hence the the thing that we
we always talk about when we're talking
about logo design is
if you reduce it down to a half inch by
half inch what's left
and so it needs to reduce or you need to
design
a responsive logo where it has the icon
version and then it can grow depending
on
the amount of screen real estate it can
have
i'm noticing that uh there's quite an
international group today tuning in so
there's some love from sri lanka of
course
somebody is in from pakistan so hello
how are you
i'm sure there's a bunch of people that
are going to type in now
where they're from but just want to say
hello to all of you
and thanks for tuning in today now i'm
just shortlisting
some of the marks that i liked and
refining them
so once like this teardrop shape
yeah along with a couple of others so
i'm shortlisting as i go and i'm
combining that with the word marks that
i've sketched out
seeing how it feels when they're
combined
different weights uh different
combinations and
i like your approach to all this
exploration it's like you like you said
you're trying different weights
different logos different symbols
different lock-ups
yeah
yeah
oh there goes everybody else saying
where they're from did it happen
yeah we got morocco egypt
kenya indonesia brazil
houston
hello my brothers from another mother
from vietnam
i'm testing the logo on different
colored background this is the capital
one blue
how it looks i'm sort of refining it
further
so that i can decide between the two
options that i have
you saw the last two contenders
so the one that i'm working on now it
was starting to look
more like a g then yeah i was going to
say
it's like when you have money you're a g
right
so i ended up dropping that just
dropping
well it's hot just like that
my new studio album drops this uh next
week guys so
just let you know
[Laughter]
it's a little slow on the trigger there
jonah
so you started in black and white and
then once you've gotten to
as a selection of the ones that you like
then you went to
see how it looks in color or with the
brand colors gotcha
just inverted out right now so
seeing see what it looks like inverted
right
just on different colored backgrounds as
well
so i'm trying another option where it's
it's not tilted
but i like the tilt of the mark because
it gives you
some dynamism of the sea
now i'm moving on to illustrator i'm
quickly
creating the mark which is a simple
shape
and now i'm trying to match
the logo type sketches with an actual
font
so you're busting out all the different
sensor typefaces that you have
access to it's what fits so i downloaded
a couple of fonts that i liked
and i'm testing those
so what i'm going for is a
clean sans serif font that with a
high x height so that it reads better in
small scales
sort of approachable but not as
clean as a geometric sense but uh i
think it's called a
neo grotesque like okay same same
category as um
helvetica so it's somewhere in between
so i'm looking at uh the kerning
using some shapes for my references
now just so that we're sure neck one
luke is saying chris just focused on the
design
and and neck one what i want to say to
you is i thought you tuned in for the
comedy the antics the the charm and the
charisma and design was just the extra
so you're telling me don't quit my day
job okay
[Laughter]
flame cat love from sweden thank you
very much how are you
thank you what are you gonna say mark
good
i'm trying to make that interesting here
man i i was gonna say there goes logo
redo
look you can't spell redo without doubt
let me just tell you that much right now
more jokes he's got more of him
can't stop this guy can't stop can't
stop don't touch this
i'm looking at the negative space here
and
trying to balance the mark with the logo
type
and looking at different scales how big
should the mark be
in comparison to the logo type
doing a lot of versions testing them i
actually
showed this to a couple of my colleagues
as well to get their opinion on
when you work on something for this long
you tend to miss something so
it's better to get some feedback if
that's an option for you
yeah are you mainly
looking at these proportions by eye or
using type some type of measurement or
no it's all visual i tried actually
measuring the
the negative space but it doesn't really
work yep
so i'm working on the color i'm going
for a
darker shade of blue and
sort of toning down the saturation of
the
red because it was a bit too harsh the
red that they originally had
creating some accent colors that i can
use
i'm not really focusing on the the
colors and the type
as much as the logo so all right
so there's a comment here that i have to
read it's from bic iron
bora he's saying michael beirut says
nobody wants a completely new logo
and he thinks we should talk about this
now what you're doing is a very
radical departure from what they used to
have and it i think it's a designer's
fantasy to just take any logo and just
change it all the way around
but you can see that most companies have
so much brand equity
that if you're driving down the street
and you saw potentially what you're
going to finish with they're going to
have a hard time like is that the same
capital one or is this
some sub brand is this a ripoff or are
they trying to capitalize on the
confusion of the marketplace what's
going on
i think it's it's a it's a it's a
case-by-case
issue well when it's something like
capital one and there are serious
problems with it
you have to take that decision to create
something new
and it it also makes sense because they
have the budget to
familiarize the logo with their market
as well
and without sticking with something that
clearly doesn't work
not saying that it's the only option
that you can
go for a gradual like a faced
design in your research did you come
across
what the meaning of the boomerang shape
or the arc
what it's supposed to symbolize
actually i couldn't find much but i read
somewhere that uh
what they were trying to do was trying
to uh
uh make the brand modern and hip that
was their thinking but this was off
of a a design article by uh
someone i forget the the publication it
was bloomberg
or something like that
but it clearly didn't work
hip in their words was just flipping a
nike swoosh and then
widening it yeah or something
or something like that yeah
okay so what else are we looking at now
let me share the
presentation again okay so while we do
that let's see what else is going on
so what do you guys think i want to ask
the people who are tuning in live today
all 548 of you
when when taking on a brand that's
really well established how far
should we go in terms of creating a
completely new thing
or trying to keep some of the heritage i
mean easily here
in the exploration i've seen thus far
i'm just wondering if you can
have a slight nod to anything so that
there's some connective tissue to the
old dna
uh let me hear your opinions on this
okay so
now we're back to is this your deck now
yes um okay am i on full screen yep
no is it on full screen jonah
are you not seeing this do you see my
okay it's okay
i see it's me i get it it's my screen
all right um uh here are some of the
explorations that i've done
i really like the the
the mark marks number six uh
because of its symmetry and uh
but i decided to drop that because um it
seemed a lot similar in my head at least
uh like the
chase logo so
i moved towards the c which is
a combination of uh
c and the number one the number one
actually combines
and it's shown in the negative space
and i've tilted the logo so that it
brings some
dynast dynamism to the logo mark
as opposed to a static mock
and bold and strong
very apt for a financial institution
so he his logo type as i said
a sensitive very approachable high
x height so it reads better in small
scale
i think it's the right balance between
modern and still
approachable very clean looking
yeah i want to also read that's comment
fajit ali
balagun said he just got home now he ran
in here
well glad to have you here watching with
us here jonah
like is youtube like really blurry for
you
i'm watching youtube right now it's it's
so blurry
is it my connection are my kids hogging
up all my bandwidth here
just looking okay on my end oh look at
this quality 360p
what is wrong with that let me go 1080.
there we go oh okay okay everything's
like what's wrong with my vision i can't
see anything
okay so you you decided to do
a very geometric very bold square
c with the one embedded on the inside
and you tilted it 45 degrees so that
it has some energy to it right yeah
okay now there's always two ways of
interpreting something that's been
tilted like this it's either
it's unbalanced or unhinged or
there's some visual tension and it's
actually very balanced i could hold this
position
but a lot of the marks that you shared
earlier i have this really solid base so
it doesn't feel like it's going to tip
over
but it i can see you making an argument
for both ways because
if it's centered like this it's like how
is it staying together but
it also for a bank you you may run into
some issues like it does it's not going
to take a lot for it to topple over
so there's some something there i
actually um
did a version where it's it's actually
not tilted
so it's it looks like a lowercase n and
that was sort of
the problem as well oh when you tilted
it like
uh 45 degrees to the right clockwise yes
yeah that would look like an n
so if you tilted 45 degrees the other
way then it would really read as a c but
then you lose the one
i i understand the rationale as to why
you put it exactly this angle because
you can see the c and you can also
interpret that there's a one in there
okay let's keep going
all right this is the logo on white
and i've tested this out on the brand
colors
i hope they work in one color and
so this is how the logo works in
different scales
you can see that the the logo mark even
in pixel scale it
it reads clearly and that's the color
palette that i've
come up with pretty pretty basic for now
but uh
and so handsome colors i like it
uh the type specimen i've used the same
type for for this example but if i were
to
do the design again for a real project i
would
go with a different font to create some
contrast between the logo and the type
and now we are moving into logo usage
the logo mock-ups everybody's favorite
part
there we go here are some
mock-ups of business cards um
using two color combinations they can
also use
different print effects if they want to
because the logo works really well
in in one color as well yeah is that
the real ceo's name richard fairbank yes
it is
wow what a great name to run a bank
richard fairbank
like my name should be chris classic
design
[Laughter]
i think fairbank i mean just think about
that guys yeah talk about that
not a shady bank no not a shitty bank a
fair bank
all right got the job facebook's name
here we have some stationary um i've
tried to create a
pattern out of the logo like
interlocking
but pretty simple i'm wearing the
opacity a bit and i'm using the logo
again
on the annual report cover to show some
arrows and progress again
you have to look at this at full 1080p
because there's this very subtle
pattern that he's running on the planner
and i really like that
hit of color pop of color that the
rubber band that runs across it or the
ribbon or whatever that is
it's it's really nice like when you use
really brilliant saturated colors
you have to use them very sparingly and
when used in that way it could really
pop so you can see like on each one of
these
pieces collateral the annual report
there's a little color for the capital
one but he doesn't go overboard the
whole thing is not this
really brilliant red color right a
little bit goes a long way
and even ties it in with that nicely
placed in pencil
okay keep going all right um this
is a mock-up of a credit card i'm
exploring how the
logo works in one color and
and as a co-branding as well a
platinum logo along with the main logo
and did some designs for placeholder
designs for social media
how the logo can work the mark can work
in
independently and i'm using a slight
uh blue color grading on the images as
well so
they look like the same thing
and uh here are some examples of
uh the logo as a fabricon for the
website
and it has an app icon working in
smaller scales
and a mock-up of their mobile app
and here's an image of one of the
capital one cafes and how the logo
can live there
that looks real yeah
this is the headquarters uh the capital
one tower
in mclean virginia and
the next one is the lobby
same place i really love how
this logo can work as a single color in
in a metallic finish when you
put it in like mock it up like this you
really
feel that it really fits with whatever
space that it works in
so at this point i'm quite happy with
what i've come up with
so i also wanted to see how this would
work
in a smaller sort of like a mini branch
and how it can look at night this is
probably my favorite mock-up so far
because you're using materials it feels
dimensional
and i love the color blocking that's
achieved it reminds me
of the original blocking of colors that
you put together to say this is going to
be the color palette
there's something that's just really
handsome about a strong grid
all right i want to read a comment here
from
pineda he's saying that c still looks
like the
chase logo and he's like this could have
the tropicana effect
well that's that's a take on this okay
but let's keep going here
okay um that's about it from now uh okay
that's that's that if if you guys have
any questions in the comment section i
would
upload okay why don't we do this because
it takes a minute for people to be able
to formulate their questions
we have a few more minutes here before i
have to bounce to my next thing but what
i want to do is bounce
to my slide here so jonah if you can do
me the honors here
so the original on the left is the
capital one logo which has gone
through very subtle evolution since its
origin
it has um a
bold oblique sensor of typeface upper
lower case and then it has
an italic serif type phase and the
juxtaposing those two with a offset
baseline
and this boomerang shape thing which
could be like the motorola logo or the
nike logo there's
i mean it's impossible these days to
draw a tapered shape that's on an arc
and not have somebody say
it reminds me of something else and they
did go through
a very subtle redesign and then another
redesign but
this is essentially the logo they have
and they're grown to be quite a sizable
company
on the right hand side of course is the
revised logo designed by indica
and he's taken on to try to simplify it
to make it more modern and contemporary
to
fit within what contemporary visual
languages of banks
according to that quilt he put together
and he's designed a c
that's very block solid it reduces down
really well
and the counter the negative space in
the c
itself has an added benefit of
potentially reading as a one
and he's using one bold and
semi-bold or something you know there's
two slightly different weights here if
i'm reading this correctly and he's he's
decided to keep it all on one baseline
so instead of having the baseline shift
which creates that juxtaposition
he's creating the shift in tilting the
logo 45 degrees and creating this
more dynamic icon now
some critique and some feedback from me
whoa there's a big old chat thing there
mark
36 big ones 36 big ones jonah where's
that
oh yes oh slow you're missing every
opportunity
okay whatevs okay so here i'm gonna give
you my feedback and then i'm gonna turn
over to the audience to say
right now do you prefer the original
type in one
for the original capital one or type in
in the comments
two for the re redesign
logo designed by indica number two for
the
new capital one logo okay so one for the
original two for the
new one now as you guys are thinking
about which one you want to vote for
um i want to say a couple of things yes
this feels much more modern it feels
really contemporary
you're using some some sans-serif
grotesque typeface right so this is
it's really cool i for one would have
liked greater contrast between the
weight of capital versus one
i think capital is very important and
you can see in the original the weight
is like extra extra bold
or black versus like regular and i think
the contrast difference between the two
is really important
and i like how you've
done the one in all caps so that it
reads as
capital one versus capital
a and that's really important so driving
the difference in weight
is really really important for
legibility
and that's why they did the baseline
shift there and switch the typeface in
the original
designing abstract simple geometric
marks is very difficult to do
because it seems hypersubjective and
it's like it's very difficult to find
something that
isn't already done right and so he had
said this too it's like
back when they did the chase bank it was
rather easy to be able to create a mark
that's new and unique and different
but these days it's so so so hard
because you're gonna be running into
small companies the big companies and
these shapes it's very difficult to make
new and fresh
my one um maybe adjustment
that i would make or suggest to you is
to try to make the counter then the one
shape
read a little bit more like this thing
that you can discover and find
because one could argue it's just the
negative space but if you if there were
a little
tip of like the top of the one or
something in there where
really read as a one so here's a crazy
suggestion that may not look good at all
but actually to use a serif
one inside that negative space so it's a
red square solid with a white serif
typeface
one just to say like hey we still
remember the original logo because
there's an element of the serif that i'm
missing
and that would be my one suggestion so
that it's very clear you see the c you
see the one
you get them both okay what are people
saying here
so lots of votes come in but there's a
good mix of one and twos but i
without counting everything up most
people like to revise
so yes yeah okay so let's read the
comment from jtr
thank you very much for supporting the
channel jtr
special thanks to you guys for what you
do thanks to you we are able to grow
and help our communities through art and
design cheers thank you very much
really appreciate you thanks gtr yeah
all right mark what else are we gonna do
now
um well yeah not a whole lot more
questions if you guys have questions
throw them there
down in the chat um you know indica went
through the process and someone was
asking
why he chose that specific word mark
at the end out of all of the sketches
indica i know you talked a little bit
about why you like the simplicity of it
but anything else you'd want to comment
on
just why you chose that one i think it
it was the simplicity of it as well
but all this time i was questioning
whether it's whether it's too
simple whether it's too common so i i
had this thought
at the back of my head but uh after
listening to some talks by sagihave
and tom geisma it sort of convinced me
to go
ahead with this option
very good okay we're we're seeing if
there's any other comments or questions
that are coming in
of course the people always ask this
question and this has come from
devanesh divi yansh
my god that's hard to say okay any
mock-up inspiration
sources where do you find your images
can you share some of the mock-up
resources that you're using
actually all of these are created from
scratch on photoshop
geez oh wow uh
every image is from free stock sites i
think most of it
came from unsplash and some images from
shutterstock i think
like there you have it
well if he had taken the i i suspected
that at least some of the images he had
to create
from scratch because he said that's the
capital one tower
and as far as i know that's too specific
nobody's gonna do a capital one tower
mock-up for you so you probably had to
clone out the original
signage there and then build your own
right yes that was from shutterstock oh
it is
so it's not really from the capital one
tower it is
so i phoned it out i see i see okay
beautiful
good job there okay thank you yeah
all right
okay i don't know i i don't know about
that question or comment there
so the question here there's a good
question here it says that for big corp
corporations is it better to have a
simple mark
and indica what's your take on that and
i'll i'll chime in as well
i think for it doesn't matter whether
it's a big corporate or not
the simpler the mark the better because
uh
for a bank like uh capital one they
they'd be constantly pushing their
marketing and messaging
throughout so people would be seeing
this so
with time they would associate uh
whatever logo
that we've come up with and it will
register in the
consumer's heads so the simpler the
better
that's my take on it and i would
generally agree with you except for i
think sometimes
in smaller more niche based industries
that you can have
a mark that is more intricate not to say
that
intricate is the opposite of simple it
could be simple and
intricate in its design and one of the
examples is i i love burberry's old logo
with the knight on the horse
and if you if you're into fashion brands
like the ralph lauren
polo horse is very iconic it tells a
whole story
and it communicates the message really
well it's a little complicated it's
drawing but
i think there's some things that you can
do that feel really appropriate
so when burberry moved away from that
mark it was like oh shoot
i i like what they're doing now it's a
very bold sans-serif
typeface but i i miss that mark
and there are other brands like that my
coach also
and it what we want to do is to make
sure what we're doing is appropriate
is memorable and unique and those are
really important and so for super niche
kind of brands yes you could you can get
away with more
and but that doesn't mean that you
should go and make it overly decorative
just because
and you also have to think about how
will this age
in 5 10 20 years or is the
company going to need to redesign their
logo every three years
so in in kind of choosing to be very
disciplined and use a lot of restraint
you're able to use simple geometric
shapes that
have lasted and and survived the test of
time
the chase logo was designed over 60
years ago i think
and it still looks good today maybe the
word mark itself needs a little updating
but the chase icon
is so strong and bold as were many of
the ones that you shared
with us on you know during your research
phase so
good question okay oh our good friend
local therapist herself hadil syed ahmad
is on
thank you very much for tuning in hadiya
and hidal is cooking up something
massive so i'm i'm sure it's going to
just drain all of her energy but
she's been i've been chatting with her
so she's going to be doing something so
you guys look out for that
okay uh i think uh mark any last
questions before we get out of here
um someone's asking about font resources
if uh
you can't afford the expensive ones
online any resources there's a good
question
uh actually most of these were from
google fonts which is free in most cases
i think
and i tried to
make it uh use use
free resources whenever possible so
it's mostly google font what i'm using
right now is a google font
variable google phone
nice okay a lot of you guys don't know
this but if you have a creative cloud
subscription it comes with adobe's vast
type library that you get to use on your
projects
for free included with your creative
cloud subscription now the question is
this
and i'm going to ask you guys this
question because i'm actually working on
a deal with monotype
to give you this massive bundle of what
i would consider my essential typefaces
at a ginormous discount but i have to
ask you this question
if you're going to be a lifetime
subscriber to
creative cloud and they have the
typefaces you don't technically own them
you can just use them for whatever you
want
do you want to have a copy where you can
own
in case you ever move away from creative
cloud
so that's the question for you guys to
contemplate i'd love to hear your
response to that because
it will impact the decision that i'm
making in curating
a typeface selection right so i want to
put together a
really beautiful list of typefaces that
you can use for the end of time
but i wanted to know should i include
the ones that
overlap with what's available on
creative cloud or not do you want to own
them all
are you comfortable with a subscription
based model so so google has free fonts
if you type in free font you you will
find typefaces there
they're not always well drawn they're
missing complete sets
but maybe that's not what you need at
this point in time
and the the ones that come with
adobe are should be sufficient for you
to design most of what you want
anything else i wouldn't worry about it
you don't need a font the font
is not going to make your design you
make the design
not the font okay all right
there's one more comment here and before
we get out of here from ingrid
burgess torres and and
she's saying the work you do is
sensational you're you help me it grows
so much and i thank you for all that
thank you very much ingrid for your
support of the channel
i guess guys before i drag this on a
little longer than it needs to be
i'm going to thank my guest today for
doing this
his name is indiga tilika
and he's from columbus sri lanka we love
seeing
the diverse community of designer from
designers from all over the globe
participating in
in this conversation with us if you guys
want to follow him on social media
he's at indica but the in the eye is
spelt with a
number one one indica
capital one in one day
[Laughter]
sorry you guys i'm still on it i'm still
honest okay
and you can look up his work at
indica.com again
the i spelt with the number one
with a name like indica i would figure
you would just be able to get the i but
i guess somebody else has that
is that why you did that yes um some
design company that was registered in
1995
or something like that i see they beat
you too
okay all right guys that's it for us
today i think we have another live
stream tomorrow
right mark yes we do we do with another
logo therapy session logo redesign logo
redo
so i hope you guys will tune in for that
don't forget to like
comment and subscribe and hit that bell
for notifications guys
thank you very much for being part of
our one billion mission to impact a
billion a billion lives on planet earth
jonah's gonna play the music any second
because i'm almost out of breath but if
you haven't done so
you guys can support me if you wish and
send me some money via venmo
i'm at christo that's it for us you guys
have a wonderful day until
tomorrow so tomorrow yeah i was gonna
say until next time until
tomorrow thank you guys bye everybody